so if you can see here I divided this
sentence into three parts car wash DVDs
this here is little Iranian a tree
Chester so I want to go to Rome
Thomas Thomas Cazale that it's a
beautiful city
static receiver got it and you see these
small things here
it's his Nikes dish that introduced
pauses was in the shade Linea Posen now
let me show you this in more detail the
vegetable editor Lila
so first of all once again if you have a
complex system and you break it down in
smaller parts this produces serious
there was less nervous Castlevania it
was delayed even a bowl a milky chest
it's easier one would lecture to imitate
it and to utter it to pronounce semi 0s
proudly present a Shana prime name of
resistant because normally if you're
told to say a sentence established
niacin omnipresent simply lasagna and
this is a long sentence a little bit
logic then you get lost inside
don't move nutrient to the Presidium
motion petty let's put it so I normally
a sound advice is to divide it there and
just tell you you can see first I want
to go to Rome take a pause it can last
one second and it still sounds natural
if I say I want to go to Rome because
they told me that it's a beautiful city
it still sounds natural us draws drama
Sevilla trauma Cudas citrus psyllid lien
applet lasagna Napoli milky Kooskia just
pause the video suppose at the stash not
linear interpolation because hydration
is just so the most important one of the
most important markers as I call it is
this form this is a mocha version exact
of market of cut cockiness of I devoted
a snack which is which is means that the
voice stops for microsecond and you can
breathe that particular business edge
store with your suppose it would have a
most the site this is not a necessary
marker but you can use it
besides lenovo more still responds of it
because it's obvious that when you
divide a sentence into chunks but a
misogynistic a cadaver is the
Leidseplein aku skills the words that
are in the chunk Slava Catarina who eats
of nutri cache de Vaca Sushma you can
already tell that they are just one
single sound emotional it Palacios
Chinese which had [ __ ] LEED status
literally in a khaki Gina's book so what
I say I want to go to Rome could I go to
France I want to go to just one sound
[ __ ] cookies in this book even if it's
four words in our mind I want to go to
Rome Ashley six his mother understand uh
she says nine he was pretty mild attack
ox rested in the sloth